hi everyone my name is philip
i'm a machine learning engineer at
hugging phase and also the tech lead for
our partnership with aws
i will show you in a few minutes how you
can deploy hiking phase transformers
from dehydrating phase hub to amazon
sagemaker for inference
amazon sagemaker is a fully managed
machine learning service that provides
everyone with the ability to build
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly together with aws we have built
an inference optimized solution to
deploy a transformer model
as sagemaker endpoints let's get started
we are going to use the sagemaker
notebook instance to deploy our model
using a sagemaker notebook instance is
not a requirement to deploy your model
you can also use sagemaker studio or
deploy a model from your local machine
the first step we need to do is to
choose a model from the hugging phase
hub
the hiking phase hub offers over 10 000
different models
fine-tuned on nlp vision and speech in
this example we
want to use a model fine tune on
question answering
and we also want to be it quick
therefore we select the digital bird
base cased
distal squad model we copy the model id
and go back to our notebook instance
to be able to deploy a model from the
hub to
sagemaker we need to create a hugging
face model class
this model class contains all the
configuration
for our hub model as the model id
and our task in this case question
and the ring after that
we can create our hugging face model
and run the dot deploy method dot deploy
method
will create our sagemaker endpoint and
we can pass in the initial instance
count
basically we can define on how many
instances we
want our endpoint to deploy it and the
instance type in this case i went with
the m5 instance which is a
cpu based image
the deploy will now create our sagemaker
endpoint which takes around 5 minutes
the endpoint has been successfully
deployed to sagemaker and can now be
used for inference
the benefit of using the python
sagemaker sdk is that the
deploy method automatically returns
predictor class which we can use to
request our endpoint with the dot
predict method
therefore we need to define our inputs
in this example
since it's a question answering model we
have our context my name is philip and i
live in nuremberg
this model is used with stage maker for
inference and
our question what is used for inference
and our request
has been successfully executed and the
model
successfully predicted the correct
answer what is used for
inference its sagemaker after you are
done testing or requesting your endpoint
you can run predictor
dot delete endpoint this will clean up
everything on sagemaker
and make sure everything is deleted
properly if you want to learn more
about packing face on amazon sagemaker
check out huggingface.co
maker